[Musique]
elise lucet bonjour bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle think ur view on
aurait besoin de vos avis vos lumières
ont concernant le journalisme la
protection des journalismes
d'investigation a essayé qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire
sur la protection des journalistes
d'investigation la meilleure des
protections déjà c'est la discrétion
donc en général quand on fait une
investigation en l'occurrence dans
l'équipe de cash on est extrêmement
discret on en parle très peu à
l'extérieur donc on n'est pas parano
mais il ya des conversations qu'on a que
en face à face son téléphone portable
dans un bureau
on a parfois les ordis cryptée parfois
pas encore assez mais on est aussi très
discret par rapport tout simplement à la
profession et aux personnes qu'on va
aller interviewer qui sont les personnes
sensibles dans un dossier c'est à dire
que on va prendre le dossier comme des
cercles concentriques on va commencer
vraiment l' enquête par les siècles
cercle extérieur de l enquête et plus ça
va aller plus on va se rapprocher du
coeur nucléaire de l'enquète mais les
personnes qui sont au coeur nucléaire de
l'enquète ne vont l'apprendre que très
tard c'est à dire qu'en général on ne
les tient au courant du fait qu'on a
enquêté sur eux que dans les toutes
dernières semaines ce qui nous permet de
travailler tranquillement pendant des
mois sans qu'il ne soit au courant la
plupart du temps en tout cas je l'espère
mais ça a l'air de marcher et de de
n'arriver au centre nucléaire
c'est-à-dire aux deux ou trois personnes
à interview qui sont mis en cause dans
ce dossier qu'au tout dernier moment et
ça leur donne un peu de connaissances
sur notre niveau à nous de connaissance
du dossier
ils sont en général
pas très optimiste sur le savoir
journalistique qui pensent que les
journalistes ne savent pas grand chose
de ce qu'ils racontent ils sont souvent
surpris de notre niveau de connaissance
et quand on arrive à faire ces
interviews là avec un tel niveau de
connaissance et souvent des documents
confidentiels
qu'on a réussi à récupérer tout au long
de nos moi d'en quête évidemment
l'interview prend une toute autre
tournure au départ ils savaient même pas
que moi la journaliste du 13h je faisais
ce genre d' enquête donc c'était encore
plus pratique maintenant malheureusement
général quand ils voient arriver ils
savent un peu ce qui les attendent
d'accord dites moi le consortium de
journalistes qui a sorti les panama
peppers s'apprête à ressortir les panama
paper 2 le 9 qu'est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire aujourd'hui nous sommes le
4 mai très franchement nous on a été on
est membre de l'aed j'ai c'est à dire
que cache investigations en fait partie
pas par hasard dans la mesure où la ici
hadjer recrute des gens et
d'investigation dans le monde entier en
fonction à la fois de leur coopération à
la csg ce qui a été notre cas puisque
par le passé on a travaillé notamment
sur le luxe leaks
on a été au démarrage de luxe l'x et
donc ils se sont inspirés de tout le
travail qu'on avait pu faire sur le luxe
l'x pour ensuite continuer l'enquète mai
donc tous les journalistes
d'investigation des panamas papers ont
été recrutés comme ça nous on a
travaillé dessus pendant des mois avec
eux
lifesize est extrêmement sélective sur
les journalistes recrutés
sauf parfois dans des pays où c'est
extrêmement compliqué de faire du
journalisme d'investigation
donc nous on s'est retrouvé dans ce
consortium qui achètent à la tête de
l'eau alors c'est un consortium qui a
été monté à washington franchement j'en
ai oublié j'ai oublié le nom du
directeur mais c'est pas tellement
important de savoir qui en est le
directeur ce qui est le plus important
c'est que c'est la première fois que le
journalisme d'investigation travail de
manière coordonnée souvent
l'investigation c'est quelque chose
d'individuel mêmes d'individualistes ces
terres sont des gens qui travaillent
dans le plus grand secret tout seul
déjà cash est un peu une exception c'est
à dire que le fait que 20 juin
d'investigation travailler ensemble
mediapart en est une autre exception
mais le plus important de la sgcc ce
côté le collectif de journalistes
d'investigation qui se met en place dans
le monde et je crois que ça effraie
beaucoup de gens parce que tout à coup
on a acquis grâce à ça une force de
frappe très importante
impressionnante mais avec des codes
extrêmement strictes c'est que chacun
d'entre nous doit respecter les codes de
la csg sur l'enquêté panama papers on a
tous travaillé pendant des mois certains
plus tardivement que d'autres mais on a
tous travaillé pendant des mois on avait
l'obligation de l'interviewer justement
le coeur nucléaire que trois semaines
avant la sortie mondiale on avait tous
la même heure et le même jour de sortie
mondiale on avait tous des fichiers
cryptés chacun avait un coach du frud
chiffrées chacun avait un code et donc
même à l'intérieur de cash
investigations pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée seules deux personnes avaient
accès réellement aux fichiers depuis un
terminal sécurisé oui c'est que vous et
comment franchement moi je ne le sais
pas donc c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
rassurant que je ne sache pas ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que pour rentrer
dans la csg en revanche la sécurisation
des terminaux doit être optimum et c'est
une requête très claire de la cciad on
peut pas être amateur de ce genre de
chose quand on a trois cent soixante
journalistes dans le monde 110 médias
qui travaillent sur le même énorme
dossier
on ne peut pas se permettre d'être
d'amateurisme c'est juste impossible
donc le 9 mai on va avoir panama peur
d'eux
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
moi pas grand chose nous cache
investigations on n'ira pas sur le
panneau rappeur de serrekunda coup on a
vraiment travaillé sur le panama paper 1
on ya travaillé très longtemps et comme
chacune de nos émissions fait l'objet
d'un monde en quête on n'a pas pu
travailler sur le 2
je pense que il ya encore beaucoup
d'informations
ça il ya tellement de documents à
traiter que je pense qu'on en entendra
parler des panamas papers pendant assez
longtemps nous on considère que sur la
france en ce qui nous concerne à cash
investigations avec une nécessité d'un
land enquête on a fait ce qu'on avait à
faire mais ce que je sais ce que je
pensais vraiment intéressant dans la mjc
le relais que chacun peut prendre et la
manière dont à chaque fois on sait que
chaque document va être exploité chaque
document intéressant va être exploité à
partir du moment où il est entre les
mains de cette communauté de
journalistes il sera exploité jusqu'au
bout
vous avez un de vos collègues qui mise
en examen pour les lucs slicks edwards
père comment ça se passe en ce moment
comment il va mieux il va beaucoup mieux
parce que
en fait il est traduit en justice avec
deux lanceurs d'alert et
et l'un d'entre eux
et
jusqu alors était dans une position
extrêmement compliqué
pricewaterhousecoopers qui est le
cabinet
d'expertisé et d'optimisation fiscale
pour lequel il travaillait a tout fait
pour l'intimider le mot est extrêmement
faible il lui a fait signer une sorte de
convention qu'il avait gardé secrètes
cercle à un moment où il se trouvait à
l'hôpital on l'a appelé en lui disant
qu' il ya eu un cambriolage chez lui il
est entré il ay s'est retrouvé face à la
fois des gendarmes et des gens de
pricewaterhousecoopers chez lui dans sa
maison avec sa femme et qu'on lui a dit
très clairement que s'il continuait à
faire que il avait été identifié comme
l'un des landes sordes alerte et que
s'ils continuent à faire fuiter des
informations et surtout s'il ne
chargeait pas le premier danseur d'
alerte et le journaliste en l'occurrence
edwards père un autre journaliste ça
allait très mal se passer pour lui il a
signé une convention secrète et la
chance a été que cette convention
secrète a été dévoilé lors du procès est
donc selon cela en alerte qui
jusqu'àlors charge est plutôt notre
journaliste l'a totalement déchargée en
disant qu' à aucun moment edwards ne
l'avait obligé à sortir des documents
que c'était bien lui qui avait pris
contact avec nous que nous on s'était
comporté comme tout journaliste
d'investigation doit le faire avec une
source et jamais en poussant la source à
aller chercher plus de documents en
pilotant la source de l'extérieur et
qu'on avait donc bien respecté les
règles de deux journalistes qui sont
vraiment des règles de base vis-à-vis
d'une source et donc qu en aucun cas
vous pouvez avoir être accusé edouard en
l'occurrence de complicité par rapport
au vol de documents donc je pense
qu'edouard va beaucoup mieux depuis
cette audition qui a eu lieu vendredi
dernier le procès moi je dois l'avoir là
au téléphone parce que le procès vient
de prendre fin il sera calé la
condamnation en gros d'après ce que j'ai
compris dans trois semaines et on sera
tous mais quand je dis tous et pas à
cash investigations c'est tous les
juristes qui s'occupe d'investigation
économique extrêmement attentif à ce qui
va se passer parce qu'on sent bien que
face à une offensive des gens il
investit gassion qui s'appelle la haye
il ya aussi une offensive en face des
multinationales qui est là qui est très
présente qui veut tenter d'ancrer les a
fait un secret des affaires ça fait
partie de l'effectif demande offensif
qui est menée et donc il ya le c'est du
luxembourg dont on va connaître le
résultat assez rapidement qui va être un
signal extrêmement fort et d'autre part
le secret des affaires la directive
européenne qui est passé certes en ayant
été modifié mais qui ne nous convient
toujours pas et pour laquelle
malheureusement la plupart des députés
européens français ont voté pour quoi ça
vous convient pas parce que
je vais vous prendre un cas concret en
gros une entreprise qui a le sentiment
qu'on porte atteinte au secret de ses
affaires prenons philip morris par
exemple sur laquelle nous avons enquêté
à cash investigations à partir du moment
où moi je vais aller voir le pdg de
phillip morris avec des documents
confidentiels internes 2 philip morris
qui révèle des stratégies de lobbing
extrêmement forte et à quel point ils
ont pu influencer des décisions
européennes sur les directives sont et
sur la directive tabac moi si je vais
voir le pdg de philip morris et que je
lui montre ses documents ce que je fais
régulièrement parce qu'une interview
devient encore plus évidemment pugnacais
offensive intéressante si on a tous ces
documents en main et qu'on met des mois
à les accumuler
si je montre au pdg de philip morris ces
documents à partir du moment où il sait
que je les ai romain il peut décider de
faire ouvrir
une information judiciaire est donc de
tenter de nous poursuivre et même
d'empêcher la diffusion de l'émission
avant même qu'elle ne soit et c'est une
procédure bâillon clair non oui
complètement moi c'est une 106 recours
jeudi c'est une censure qui ne dit pas
son nom et c'est donner des armes aux
grandes multinationales pour tenter de
tuer dans l'oeuf toutes les révélations
d'investigation économique alors ça va
être à chaque fois à la discrétion d'un
juge donc bien sûr il y aura des
jurisprudences et ça va être extrêmement
intéressant de voir ce qui va se passer
justement dans les jurisprudences à
venir en france et dans d'autres pays
parce que je pense qu'en france la
liberté d'informer est encore un droit
souverain et que on va avoir des juges
qui vont plutôt aller dans le sens des
journalistes qui révèle ces informations
mais comme on va révéler comme on va
entre guillemets travailler sur les
enquêtes qui vont toucher des
multinationales qui ont des antennes
partout il ya des pays où la liberté
d'informer sur l'évasion fiscale par
exemple est beaucoup moins évidente on
pourra avoir des procédures judiciaires
qui vont être ouvertes en france mais
aussi au luxembourg et dans des pays où
on voit les journalistes à le feu que
fait le gouvernement français pour
protéger sa que fait le sapin que fait
françois hollande pour l'instant le
gouvernement français sur nous on a eu
beaucoup de réunions avec fleur pellerin
moment a été ministre de la culture
là depuis deux jours je sais qu'on va en
avoir avec audrey azoulay aussi c'est le
collectif informer n'est pas un délit
qui mène cette bataille et qu'il amène
plutôt bien mais il ya un peu un double
discours c'est d'un côté françois
hollande remercie très clairement le
jour des panamas papers les lanceurs
d'alerté les journalistes
d'investigation et de l'autre on attend
toujours un soutien officiel du
gouvernement français vis-à-vis des
douars perrin qu'on n'a pas eue ils
appellent ils sont pas régies réagi deux
heures avant la fin de la dernière
audition au niveau du procès ils n'ont
pas essayé de faire quelque chose mais
écoutez nous on a envoyé une lettre
ouverte à françois hollande on attend
toujours très clairement de la part de
françois hollande une prise de position
claire et que je sache regarder la
caméra lesdites la communauté des
hackers d'aller un petit peu se pencher
sur ce dossier alors je demande à la
communauté des hackers de se pencher sur
ce dossier là et je leur dis très
franchement que la liberté d'informer
elle est extrêmement importante
dans ce genre de dossiers économiques si
on ne bouge pas si on ne se mobilise
bonne si on ne se mobilise pas tous les
multinationales vont une fois de plus
gagner parce qu'elles ont énormément de
moyens bien sûr et donc des batteries
d'avocats et elles ont tenté
d'influencer
les toutes les procédures judiciaires
qui vont avoir lieu ça va être crucial
ce qui va se passer dans les semaines ou
dans les mois à venir donc c'est
maintenant qu'il faut se mobiliser c'est
maintenant qu'il faut bouger et c'est
maintenant que le gouvernement français
doit prendre position vis-à-vis des
lanceurs d alerte je dirais que c'est
quand même il ya eu des efforts de fait
dans la loi 101 par deux notamment pour
que les lanceurs d'alleurs la halle pour
que les lanceurs d'alertés pardon est un
vrai statut c'est inimaginable mais
quand je dis inimaginable de penser que
hervé falciani stéphanie gibeau
se retrouve antoine deltour se retrouve
en ayant pris des risques considérables
pour au moins stéphanie gibeau sans
travail depuis cinq ans au rsa menacé
d'être viré de son appartement parce
qu'elle n'a plus les moyens de payer son
loyer et que le gouvernement français à
qui elle a permis sûrement à terme elle
va permettre de récupérer 12 milliards
d'euros puisque c'est michel sapin lui
même qui dit qu'a priori tout l' affaire
ubs va permettre à la france de
récupérer 12 milliards d'euros ne bouge
pas le petit doigt pour aider stéphane
riboud donc ils ont peur de quoi c'était
un docteur de motivés ils ont peur de
motiver d'autres lanceurs d'alertés ont
peur de quoi ça hein ça n'était pas dans
les textes et je pense qu'il faut que
les textes de lois évoluent plus vite
par rapport à la société la société
change la société bouge il faut que les
lois évoluent plus vite ça c'est la
première chose 2 vous imaginez très bien
que face à des lanceurs des rays comme
cela les grandes sociétés bouge
énormément ils font un lobbying de folie
vis-à-vis des différents gouvernements
pour qu'il n'y ait aucun statut de
protection des lanceurs d'alerté pour
eux c'est un danger extrême si quelqu'un
de l'intérieur fait sortir des documents
qui sont des documents cruciaux qui
montera un moment que ces entreprises se
sont joués des lois où on fait de
l'évasion ou de l'optimisation fiscale à
outrance c'est un danger absolu donc il
ya eu un mouvement
extrêmement fort et puissant de lobbying
de ces multinationales qui ont tout fait
pour que les lanceurs dallas ne soit pas
reconnue c'est mieux dans la loi sapin 2
mais ce n'est pas encore suffisant et je
tiens à dire franchement que pour nous
aux journalistes c'est déterminant c'est
à dire que la protection des lanceurs
d'alerté
c'est la protection des gens qui à un
moment dans une entreprise constatent
des infractions graves et plutôt que de
se glisser dans le courant et dans la
tiède de leur travail et de se dire
surtout j'ai rien vu j'ai rien vu j'ai
rien entendu je dirais rien sortent du
rang prennent des risques immenses nous
parle nous confie ses documents et en
retrouve vraiment se retrouve avec une
vie brisée derrière donc nous on se doit
en tant que journalistes de protéger
aussi ces gens ça c'est la protection
des sources un maximum mais en revanche
quand ils sont mises au jour quand ils
sont découverts de les aider le plus
possible parce que c'est grâce à eux
souvent que les plus grands scandales à
arrive jusqu'aux téléspectateurs jusqu
aux auditeurs jusqu'au lecteur jusqu'au
jour qui regardent vos chaînes donc
c'est déterminant de protéger ces gens
ils sont trop seul vous avez
pratiquement un quart de siècle dans la
maison du journalisme vous venez de
quitter le journal de 13h pour vous
occuper ou du moins reprendre à peu près
la moitié de france télévisions au
niveau de l'investigation non vous avez
repris qu est la commission spéciale
complément dans quatre et je garde cache
bien se voit donc ça fait à peu près la
moitié de france télévisions
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas trop intéressé
à l'époque à l affaire clearstream et
denis robert
parce que à l'époque je n'avais pas une
émission d'investigation en ordre de
marche aussi forte que celle
d'aujourd'hui
parce que je pense que j'étais un peu
jeune aussi parce que j'en ai pas
forcément compris tous les enjeux à ce
moment là
parce que
denis était aussi un personnage pas
toujours évident à cerner en tout cas
pour la jeune journaliste que j'étais
puis qui sait pas forcément non plus
tourné vers moi à l'époque
et que je pense franchement que
denis robert a été le précurseur dans ce
journalisme là et ces lanceurs d'alerté
ont été les précurseurs cercle
aujourd'hui quand on voit les panama
papers quand on entend stéphanie j'ai
beau quand on entend thuan deltour on a
l'impression de revivre plus de dix ans
après les mêmes événements et de
comprendre à quel point
cette ampleur et l est enfin je veux
dire ce genre de pratique à une ampleur
mondiale que c'est partout que ces gens
sont persuadés qu'ils sont extrêmement
tranquille et que de temps en temps il
ya un denis robert qui est à un petit
grain de sable qui vient mettre un peu
de bazar dans nos affaires mais bon pas
trop parce qu'on on arrive à le
déstabiliser denis a eu enfin se sont
empressés voilà c'est pas je croise et
je sais a été harcelé judiciairement
parlant
découragé je crois aussi
professionnellement parlant
et que je crois que la meilleure réponse
d'ailleurs ça me fait plaisir d'entendre
à nouveau de denis robert parler
aujourd'hui c'est que la meilleure
réponse qu'on fasse à oka denis robert
d'il ya plus de dix ans c'est là ici à
jesse est à dire de dire à un moment
tout ça est trop lourd pour un
journaliste tout seul personne est assez
costaud pour subir tout ça et que la
communauté des journalistes si elle est
assez maligne et intelligente pour se
rassembler et faire groupe face à ça là
ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué alors
on a beaucoup reproché à la csg d'être
financés par son os est d'être un ersatz
de la politique étrangère américaine
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à ça
écoutez moi j'en ai pas le sentiment
pour avoir vu un peu à la manière dont
ça fonctionne
après je pense que si il ya une dérive
ou s'il ya un pilotage de la csg les
gens haïssent d'investigation qui en
font partie maintenant sont suffisamment
indépendants les uns des autres il est
vraiment pour aller voir y compris dans
le fonctionnement de laïcité s'il ya des
choses qui ne vont pas pour l'instant
moi
j'ai le sentiment mais même si plus
qu'un sentiment j'ai la certitude que la
ici hd apporte beaucoup plus de choses
positives que de questions importantes
c'est-à-dire que est ce que oui ou non
il faut se poser des questions sur
pourquoi il ya peu de révélations sur
les états unis dans les panama papers
oui bien sûr qu'il faut se poser la
question est ce qu'il faut pour autant
remettre en question tout ce que les
panama paper sont ont permis de
découvrir partout dans le monde non sire
que dans la balance pour l'instant moi
je regarde le côté positif de la csg je
pense à denis robert je me dis qu'on
fait beaucoup de chemin que évidemment
tout ça n'est pas statique et qu'il faut
pas on n'est pas trop le genre à s'auto
féliciter les uns les autres à
s'autocongratuler mais qu'en revanche on
est en train de
de monter quelque chose de fabriquer
quelque chose qui en plus sera sous les
yeux de tous les journalistes
d'investigation du monde entier donc ça
va être compliqué d'en faire quelque
chose de de vicié
et que je pense en revanche qu'on va
pouvoir apporter énormément de choses je
crois qu'il ya des gens qui commencent à
se dire waouh ils sont beaucoup ils sont
nombreux ils sont organisés ils
travaillent longtemps ils savent garder
un secret et quand ça quand
l'information sort ça fait boum donc je
pense qu'il ya quelques personnes qui
doivent se dire en ce moment où quelques
groupes qui doivent se dire en ce moment
on est un peu moins tranquille ont
engagé des tueurs tout ça non il
faudrait beaucoup de monde justement
c'est ça par rapport à denis robert
c'est denis l'a pas été tuées
physiquement mais il a été tué autrement
non il est toujours vivant ou la suit à
quatre ans les
professionnels
ont tous qui ébranlait
et même remis en cause dans la
profession mais avait été remis en cause
dans la profession par qui au par
beaucoup de gens mais nous aussi à cash
on a été mis en cause dans la profession
mediapart les aussi ceux qui font leur
boulot en fait
oui mais si vous voulez il ya moi j'aime
pas du tout être donneuse de leçons donc
chacun fait le métier comme il l'entend
on va dire que on n'a pas tous les mêmes
manières d'exercer notre profession
et que le fait qu'en france un certain
journalisme d'investigation refasse son
apparition
et pour le coup qu'on soit assez soudés
les uns avec les autres on a dérangé
plus d'un ça devient compliqué
maintenant nous contester mais j'entends
encore toutes les critiques faites
notamment vis-à-vis de fabrice arfi de
mediapart sur la sphère cahuzac là c'est
quand même énorme jean michel aphatie
qui lui réclament ses sources en direct
j'ai trouvé ça explique benoît bringer
qui a travaillé pour nous pour les
panama papers s'est fait le plaisir
quand il a été interviewé par jean
michel aphatie ya pas si longtemps que
ça au moment de la sortie des panamas
peppers de l'ue approuvent de lui
apporter la preuve du compte caché de
cahuzac au panama donc là il l'avait
sous les yeux il était un peu embêté
mais si vous voulez il ya il ya
plusieurs manières d'exercer le
journalisme moi j'ai encore une fois je
suis pas donneuse de leçons mais je
pense simplement que c'est compliqué
de critiquer des gens qui travaillent
longtemps sérieusement en collectif
alors vous avez travaillez vous avez
travaillé sur des millions et des
millions de nok leurs proches qui a été
fait dans la communauté du acquis et par
l'intermédiaire de julian assange c'est
fougue et full disclosure c'est pourquoi
nous on peut pas
digging s'était creusée
dans les plats nama bieber je sais pas
pour l'instant il ya une vraie réflexion
là dessus c'était avant c'est à dire est
ce que est ce que oui ou non
il ya une mise à disposition de tout ce
qu'on a
d'abord il ya une première question
qu'on doit se poser c'est si la mise à
disposition de tout ce qu'on a mais en
danger la source ça c'est la première
chose donc 6 à 6 mais ne serait-ce
qu'une seule seconde la source est en
danger parce que justement en révélant
tout ce qu'on a tout à coup on peut se
dire mais d'où ça vient et on peut
remonter à une personne alors il ne faut
pas le faire si à la mise en danger
d'une source c'est même pas on vous fait
pas deux comme dans les services de
renseignements vous sacrifiez pas votre
source quoi vous ne maîtrisez pas non
d'accord c'est pas possible on peut pas
faire ça vous avez un coeur une éthique
tout ça oui et puis c'est un engagement
collectif qu'on a pris tous vis-à-vis et
enfin c'est un engagement professionnel
c'est ça fait partie du b à ba du
journaliste d'investigation mais en plus
c'est un engagement collectif qu'on a
pris quand on rentre dans la communauté
de la csg on prend cet engagement donc
déjà révélé la totalité des documents
qu'on a peut être une information pour
remonter jusqu'à la source si c'est
cassé nos et après le débat sur la mise
à disposition
de tous les documents nous on l'a eue
sur sur plusieurs sur plusieurs enquêtes
et
on est encore hésitant à cash sur le
fait de quand on a en marre des
documents qui ne sont qu'entre nos mains
et de quelques-uns qui nous les ont
fourni
en marge de la mise en danger des
sources ou chasser ça se discute même
pas s'il ya mise en danger d'une source
on oublie mais après si on a un vrai
doute sur
ce côté bien sûr qu'on le met en mains
de la communauté des hackers mais pas
seulement on va le mettre tout le monde
va avoir accès à ça les multinationales
aussi elles vont peut-être savoir et
comprendre comment on travaille elles
vont peut-être décrypter des modes de
fonctionnement qui nous sont propres et
on en n'a pas très envie donc on est en
débat je dis pas que notre décision pour
l'instant elle est définitive et que on
donnera pas un moment sur des dossiers
précis ou même plus globalement des
dossiers à la communauté des hackers ou
à d'autres au grand public mais on est
encore en débat là-dessus et c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on tranche en trois
secondes juste parce qu'on en a envie
c'est pas ça je pense qu'il faut qu'on
prenne une décision réfléchie parce
qu'elle va être à elle elle sera
importante et qu'on sache exactement en
ayant pesé le pour et le contre pourquoi
on fait ça mais sur la démocratisation
de l'information y compris des
informations sensibles
moi je sais que en tout cas nous le fait
que l'on réussisse à décrocher une
émission de prime time dans une chaîne
qui s'appelle france 2 qui était la
premium de france télévisions et où on
met ce genre de démission après mme et
déjà un premier pas important parce que
on a réussi à prouver qu entre nous et
les téléspectateurs il y avait un vrai
lien c'est à dire une volonté de savoir
est que l est beaucoup plus importante
si vous voulez quand l'émission sur les
panama paper se fait 17 % de parts de
marché ces personnes et qu'en face sur
tf1 il ya une émission consacrée aux
visiteurs et qu'on les plis bien sûr que
c'est une satisfaction personnelle mais
pas que c'est quand même ça dit quelque
chose de la société d'aujourd'hui et de
la volonté de savoir le p tit est de
savoir ce qu'on cache c'est à dire
savoir ce qu'on dissimule et de bien
voir que maintenant tout le monde a
compris qu'ils avaient de très belle
opération de communication qui était
destiné au grand public mais que le
grand public il est plus près à juste
prendre les opérations de communication
et à faire semblant de croire qu'il y a
rien derrière pourquoi votre foyer parce
que le grand public il est grand et que
faut arrêter de prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles
il ya de multiples manières de
s'informer et ça ça a été une vraie
chance dans notre profession
le média unique sais c'est pas que c'est
fini mais ces morts et enterrés et tant
mieux donc il ya beaucoup de gens qui
cherchent partout qui ont des profils
différents qui n'ont pas forcément une
carte de presse mais c'est pas parce
qu'ils ont une carte de presse qu'il
cherche pas bien il ya beaucoup de gens
qui nous informent différemment après il
faut faire le tri vraiment entre le bon
grain et l'ivraie on est bien d'accord
il ya du boulot parce que sur internet
hier il ya de tout et de rien sur les
sites il ya de tout et de rien et cette
multiplication
on va dire des curieux potentiel ou des
journalistes potentiel moi je trouve a
donné d'avoir un coup de booster à la
profession nous fait qu'on a des relais
d'information dans beaucoup d'endroits
alors qu'on les avait pas ou
difficilement et en tout cas pas aussi
rapidement et puis je trouve que c'est
assez formidable parce que ça veut dire
que
les les téléspectateurs sont des
citoyens ils ont envie de savoir ils ont
envie d'agir parfois et que parfois on
se dit que derrière la télé il ya les
lanceurs d alerte potentiels de demain
et donc qu'ils sont dans une société
aujourd'hui une multinationale et qui en
regardant des émissions comme la nôtre
se disent est ce que je continue à
rester silencieux ou pas ce que vous
craignez pour votre sécurité non
non c'est pas ça enfin non très
franchement non d'abord parce que je ne
suis pas journaliste pigiste
je suis élise lucet mais je suis lucide
de france télévisions donc s'attaquer à
moi c'est quand même s'attaquer à un
groupe puissant mais on fait une cible
de choix
oui c'est peut-être une cible de choix
mais je pense être protégé aussi par par
france télévisions et par le groupe et
je pense que si quelqu'un voulait
s'attaquer à moi entre guillemets pour
faire un exemple
d'abord ça susciterait exactement la
réaction inverse c'est à dire que
il y aurait je sais pas combien de
confrères à reprendre toutes les
enquêtes que je nous n'aurions pas pu
finir donc je pense que ce serait
complètement vain on n'arrête pas un
mouvement comme celui ci et c'est pas en
s'attaquant à une personne comme moi
qu'on arrête ça encore une fois
peut-être à l'époque de denis robert en
étouffant de nice où les procès on
pouvait penser arrêter une forme de
journalisme d'investigation mais
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui ferait ça
c'est quelqu'un qui voit pas le monde
c'est quelqu'un qui comprend pas le
monde d'aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui
vit encore au 20e alors qu'on est au
21ème et le 21e va très vite qu'elle a
beaucoup de gens qui ont seulement
pardon tu m'as beaucoup des gens comme
ça oui c'est possible et où placer non
non mais c'est possible mais ce serait
une erreur ça ne servirait à rien donc
je les décourage d'avant ce service
directement à ce serait contre-productif
le risque terroriste en étant
journaliste femme reprenant des
investigations du moins des magazines
d'investigation qui peuvent
potentiellement
traiter ce genre de presse je peux vous
dire que j'avais plus dans certains pays
où j'allais que parce que parce que
parce qu'il faut je ne suis pas parano
mais faut être un tant soit peu prudent
sur ce qu'on représente et j'ai beau
vouloir m'en détacher et dire et je
pense me comporter comme une personne
normale ya un moment où comme vous le
dit fort bien on devient une cible
malgré soi donc j'en suis une malgré moi
donc il ya des pays où je ne vais plus
j'écris ce que les pays lui que j'allais
beaucoup en mauritanie à un moment parce
que j ai des attaches fortes et que avec
le désert notamment et avec les gens du
désert et où j'ai j'ai fondé une
association pour sauver des manuscrits
anciens et donc j'y suis allé j'ai pas
une vingtaine de fois j'ai évidemment je
n'y vais plus surtout surtout dans les
oasis du désert là pour le coup c'est
c'est même pas la peine mais je vais
plus au maroc je vais plus en egypte je
vais plus dans tous ces pays je vois là
je je pense qu'à un moment
il faut il faut avoir l'intelligence de
comprendre que le monde change y compris
pour soi et que et qu'on représente une
cible malgré soi vous iriez en arabie
saoudite non je pense pas
et notre communauté nous a demandé de
vous poser une question concernant un
très vieux documentaire documentaire une
très bonne émission concernant la
pédophilie oui c'est loin oui vous
n'avez pas beaucoup changé
merci see
pourquoi le sujet n'est plus abordés
comme vous l'avez fait à l'époque
maintenant dans les médias je pense
qu'il le sera pour moi je pense que
je pense que la sphère barbara en soi
est en train de réveiller les vieux
démons et je pense que c'est nécessaire
je pense que ça y est j'ai un trou de
mémoire le film qui a reçu l'oscar aux
états unis sur soie tase je pense que
spotlight est vraiment l'exemple de ce
que peut être le journalisme
d'investigation aussi un film que j'ai
adoré et c'est l'exemple de ce que peut
être le journalisme d'investigation
alors c'est du data à la papa parce que
quand on voit ce mode light ils
recherchent dans des vieux registre des
archives etc mais mais je pense qu'il ya
du travail à faire dans ce domaine et je
pense franchement qu'il faut que le
journalisme d'investigation se repent
sur ce genre de sujet qui a des choses à
faire et que quand on voit ce qui se
passe dans le diocèse de lyon ce qui s'y
est passé et ce qui s'y passe
aujourd'hui on se dit que il
ya vraiment matière à une enquête
extrêmement fouillé je pense qu'il faut
pas viser d'ailleurs seulement clergé
secure il faut il faut pas être
monomaniaque il y a il a pas que le
clergé non il n'ya pas que le clergé et
puis il ya eu un problème moi ce qui
m'intéresse le plus la danse et le
problème des institutions quelle qu'elle
soit qu'elle soit religieuse ou
politique et c'est comment à un moment
oui ou non et c'est à cette question
qu'il faut répondre des deux
institutions ont pu couvrir
organisé pour l'interrogation est en
tout cas couvrir et
on va dire dans les grandes mesures ou
pas des actes qui sont totalement
répréhensibles et juste insupportable et
inacceptable et si c'est le cas
je dire que si on se lance là dessus si
on travaille dessus je pense qu'on
trouvera des choses on a nous a fait
remonter aussi d'autres questions
concernant les 28 pages à 750 milliards
ça vous parle
28 pages concernant le report du 11
septembre
qui doit vous qui devrait disclosure
sortie
je ne voulais pas parler de la mort de
ben laden et de ska sortie derniers
seront certes il est sorti et services
secrets américains là dessus encore oui
on y arrive est donc loin des 28 pages
d'un rapport incriminant l'arabie
saoudite l'arabie saoudite a menacé de
liquider 750 milliards d'actifs aux
états unis si barack obama permettait la
divulgation des 28 pages un appareil
c'est une faute professionnelle
donc je vous l'expliquais en simple
voilà
pourquoi les 11 septembre nous on a
travaillé autour du 11 septembre
concernant la finance l aspect
économétriques du 11 septembre autour
des délits d'initiés et les poteaux
motion qui avait été mis
sur american airlines united airlines on
sait on va beaucoup creusé il ya un
professeur en suisse qui s'appelle marc
chesney de l'université de zurich
qui s'est un petit peu penché sur le
sujet et qui a été discrédité d'un coup
comme un journaliste qui mettait les
doigts il fallait pas
pourquoi les 11 septembre est un sujet
tabou chez les journalistes à salé pas
s'asseoir à côté de nous très
franchement moi je me souviens que si
vous pouvez me dire sur les délits
d'initiés autour du concept armée parce
que franchement on a par travailler tue
mais pour moi c'est pas du tout tabou
alors pas du tout du tout du tout et
pour vous dire que ce n'est pas tabou
c'est que moi je me souviens très bien
vous allez me dire que ces anciens et
c'est pas en sortant de vieilles
émissions qu'on se justifie mais ça
montre que pour moi il ya zéro tabou sur
le 11 septembre mais zéro alors
franchement 0
quand il ya eu le 11 septembre on a
extrêmement rapidement nous travailler
en ayant d'ailleurs des documents hyper
intéressant enfin moi j'avoue que j'ai
appris énormément de choses à ce
moment-là et et on se débride les yeux
là c'est dire que d'un côté on voyait
l'eau en septembre qui venait de se
produire et de l'autre on était capable
de comprendre comment les états-unis la
france pour lutter contre les russes qui
avaient pré l'afghanistan avait fourni
des armes et avait formé des gens qui
ensuite ces mêmes armes se sont
retournés contre les américains et les
mêmes gens qui a été formé se sont
retrouvés avec ben laden pour pour faire
les attentats du 11 septembre et c'était
un décryptage du 11 septembre qu'on a
fait très peu de temps après nous arrive
ça dans pièces à conviction je crois que
c'était deux mois après et alors et pour
le coup si vous voulez
là sur les implications financières à
mon avis a effectivement à creuser c'est
pas du tout un sujet tabou c'est très
intéressant et non hélas le 11 septembre
pour moi n'est absolument pas un sujet
tel alors ça fait plaisir à entendre
parce que nous on s'est amusé à regarder
comment les journalistes français avait
traité les 28 pages
à 750 milliards et je vous conseille
d'aller voir simplement faire un
une capture d'écran de ce qui est sortie
concernant ces 28 pages dans la presse
française a atterri c'est à dire il ya
trois quatre cinq articles qui se
battent en duel quoi oui alpes et puis
et puis même allez je vais dire 7 7 7 ya
mediapart qui s'est penché sur mais
après
j'espère qu'en sport franchement oui non
à se parler franchement où je vais pas
être très sympathique pour ma profession
et je me mets dedans
on change d'obsession cercle obsession
française c'est deich et c'est pas que
l'obsession française mais vu les
attentats qui vient de ceux de se
produire en france
il ya cette obsession sur des chez vous
allez pouvoir voir
énormément de papier des missions sur
des shs des angles très différents et
parfois on a la mémoire courte c'est à
dire que le temps journalistique n'est
pas forcément le temps d'une vraie bonne
enquête qui peut durer parfois à 25 ans
donc le temps journalistique est très
court nous on se bat pour que le temps
jouera ristic se rallongent chaque
enquête de cash c'est un nom en france
ça n'existait pas une enquête d'un an à
la télé ça n'existait pas ou très peu
donc on se bat pour rallonger ce temps
là mais c'est vrai qu'il faut être
honnête et se dire se regarder bien
droit en face dans le miroir et se dire
que oui on a tous à un moment
un tropisme sur un sujet et en
supportant le tropisme c'est le groupe
etat islamique et
quitte à en oublier d'autres choses qui
sont tout aussi importantes donc moi je
dirais plutôt ça
je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient la volonté
de absolument ne pas en parler c'est
juste que à un moment tout le monde
journalistique français est obsédé par
ça étant d'avoir des informations
là-dessus et pense que le 11 septembre
c'est loin c'était il ya longtemps
désir pourtant son lagon septembre
peut-être pas eu l'émergence doutant de
terrorisme vraiment on est d'accord mais
dans le temps journalistique c'est loin
c'est 15 ans c'est loin et c'est un tort
c'est à dire que moi je suis pour qu'on
revienne sur le 11 septembre je suis
pour qu'on revienne sur l' affaire
boulin je suis pour qu'on revienne sur
la pédophilie on y retravaille en
regardant ce qui s'est passé entre dans
les années 60 à 90 je suis pour tout ça
simplement c'est beaucoup de travail à
chaque fois et
ce que j'espère moi c'est susciter
beaucoup de vocations et ses murs oui
parce que il faut qu'on soit beaucoup il
faut qu'on soit beaucoup il ya une
nécessité vraiment forte
de d'avoir deux de retrouver une
communauté de journalistes
d'investigation forte en france à un
moment elle a failli disparaître
moi je dirais 70 80 il y avait quasiment
plus rien quand on a créé pièces à
conviction je crois qu'il y avait on
était deux magazines d'investigation à
se battre en duel maintenant il y en a
beaucoup plus et et puis et puis
maintenant il ya plein de manières
d'investiguer différentes c'est vrai que
vous en faites partie j'en fais partie
il ya une communauté d'investigateurs
beaucoup plus large beaucoup plus
importante et d'un journalisme wii
points 0 bien sûr on peut nourrir les
uns les autres on peut s'aider les uns
les autres sans guitare à la main et
sans chanter autour d'un feu de bois
mais pour de vrai et donc mais j'espère
susciter des vocations pas que moi mais
quand les gens regardent cash il voit
aussi mes enquêteurs qui sont à l'image
et qu'on voit beaucoup et leur
implication sur le terrain il faut
comprendre que il passe à chaque fois un
an de leur vie dans une enquête et quand
je dis dans une enquête c'est dans une
enquête c ils sont obsédés par leur
enquête pendant un an il travaille comme
comme des dingues et ça j'espère que ça
suscite des vocations ce qui me fait
extrêmement plaisir c'est ce que l'on me
renvoie c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de jeunes joueurs qui m'appelle en me
disant moi madame quand je serai grand
c'est ce set ce journalisme là que je
veux faire donc ça c'est assez
formidable et que quand je suis dans la
rue les gens qui m'arrêtent il y en a
beaucoup marc est en visite en continu
et surtout et si vous arrivez là la
moindre chose on vous soutient on est là
surtout ne lâchez rien et ça ça veut
dire que
globalement on répond à une demande
forte du public et que donc si à
l'avenir quelqu'un voulait museler cette
presse là d'investigation ça va être
compliqué ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué que qu'auparavant alors on
entend bien le fait que les gens vous
adultes parce que c'est normal ça a dû
les uns au contraire il me renvoie pas
du tout
c'est pas du fan session respect par
rapport aux épis ils sont un peu genre
continue et on vous soutient c'est il me
donne de l'énergie me donne des forces
mais pas que pour moi pour toute mon
équipe et etc ces gens vous faites
partie des gens nécessaire vous faites
votre équipe fait partie des choses
nécessaires dans dans une démocratie
d'aujourd'hui pas que moi mediapart
d'autres émission d'investigation mais
des gens qui se battent aujourd'hui pour
que la vérité émerge face à un système
de communication
qui a pris un pouvoir fout
là les gens le disent clairement ils
réclament ça ils sont pas dupes de ce
système
politique économique marketing qui s'est
mis en place ils ont le sentiment d'en
être souvent les dindons de la farce et
ils en ont marre qu'il faut qu'on
prenait cette défiance selon oui parce
que oui oui je viens on peut tout vendre
comme un produit mais à un moment il
faut arrêter de prendre les gens qui
sont en face pour des imbéciles la
politique n'est pas un produit moi je
suis désolé après qu'une multinationale
et des produits à vendre bien sûr ok ça
je l'entends je le comprends c'est son
job qu'ils fassent de l'argent bien sûr
ça je l'entends je le comprends je suis
pas dans un truc ultra gauche en dix ans
les entreprises ne doivent pas faire de
bénéfices c'est pas ça c'est après c'est
juste qu'il ya des lois des règles et
que c'est pas parce que c'est une
multinationale qu'elles doivent pas
respecter des lois et des règles nous on
nous dit souvent oui vous êtes
anticapitaliste vous détestez les
entreprises non on déteste pas les
entreprises la vie et pas noire blanche
on déteste pas les entreprises on
déteste pas les multinationales c'est
juste qu'à un moment on dit que leur
statut les multinationales ne fait pas
qu'elles peuvent s'affranchir des lois
c'est tout qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce
que vous détestez
moi j'ai pas de j'aime j'aime pas je
like pas les choses j'aime la vérité
voilà c'est tout j'aime la vérité et je
vais la chercher parfois là où ça
dérange mais il n'y a pas de j'aime pas
les chefs d'entreprise ou j'aime pas les
légendes aussi où les gens de la serra
moment on a des documents précis sur une
entreprise la manière dont elle s'est
affranchie des lois on travaille sur ces
documents on le fait sérieusement on va
au bout des choses et si à un moment un
attaché de presse un chargé de
communication de crise ou pas nous dit
non vous ne pourrez pas interviewer
monsieur machin eh ben on va tout faire
pour
il ya un think tank de journalistes qui
s'est créée récemment on a interviewé sa
présidente récemment natacha polony oui
ça s'appelle le comité orwell
ils luttent contre ce qu'ils décrivent
comme la police de la pensée qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
je ne sais pas ce qu'elle voit elle
natacha dans la police de la pensée
c'est à dire la pensée unique le fait
que à un moment d si elle est dans le
journalisme d'opinion moi j'y suis pas
mais dans le journalisme d'opinion que
toutes les opinions et le droit de
s'exprimer oui phare - ok moi je suis
pas du tout dans le journalisme
d'opinion je suis vraiment dans du pur
journalisme de l'aveyron cherche la
vérité on vérifie on trace on creuse des
sillons on voit on cherche des preuves
on veut des preuves et si on n'a pas de
preuves on n'avance pas donc on fait
peut-être voilà moi je suis le
journalisme d'opinion c'est vraiment un
métier particulier j'en fais pas partie
j'ai aucune envie d'en faire partie je
les méprise pas du tout on en a besoin
et c'est très bien d'ailleurs qu'il ya
des gens comme ça mais c'est très bien
aussi qu'on dise halte à la pensée
unique j'ai un peu l'impression d'avoir
entendu cette chanson là déjà il ya il
ya 10 ou 15 ans ou 20 ans et on l'entend
régulièrement mais je pense que c'est
bien à des moments que des journalistes
par exemple des gens s qui suivent la
politique puisse dire ça parce que c'est
vrai que et on commence à sentir que
même dans le traitement de la politique
il ya des changements il ya enfin des
changements auxquels les jours
c'est tout simple mais nous on l'a fait
mais mais mais je ne comprends pas que
qu'enfin c'est de plus en plus fait
maintenant dans les jt ou ailleurs mais
quand est ce que vous trouvez normal
qu'on emmène des journalistes dans des
voyages officiels en charter et que et
que
jamais les journalistes mais filmer les
conditions dans lesquelles ces voyages
officiels se déroule et kankan
maintenant je donne pas de leçon
maintenant on commence à voir et qu'on
attachait polony pose la question à
christine ockrent sur les réseaux de
pouvoir des bilderberg et des réunions
secrètes où la presse n'est pas conviée
mais des journalistes son contact avec
une proximité vraiment parler très
heureux car le serbe sait rien du tout
là le cercle
non si vous voulez parler de quelque
chose recommencer à parler un petit peu
trilatérale chose comme ça ce que le
cycle c'est une position otaries club
pour retraités de luxe ça s'est passé
c'est très intéressant alors lui ni
retraités diderik sedan
non mais j'approuve j'approuve et
j'applaudis les gens qui se mettent au
pied du serbe pour voir à peu près
qu'elle trône se baladent là bas par
contre il ya des plus gros dossiers si
vous voulez chercher les gars envoyez
nous envoyez nous des mails on va vous
dire vous cherchez un
donc j'en étais un les cercles du
pouvoir s'est passé est-ce que vous avez
des questions à nous poser vous non je
voulais vous dire moi par rapport aux
cercles du pouvoir c'est que j'ai et
j'ai toujours eu une position assez
radical c'est à dire que je fais partie
elle est contestable cette position mais
c'est la mienne moi je fais partie des
journalistes qui pensent qu' on ne peut
pas petit déjeuner déjeuner dîner avec
des hommes politiques si ensuite on veut
faire des investigations
digne de ce nom donc je suis très
lointaine de ce cercle là ils le savent
très bien je ne les vois que pour les
interviewer en général sur des dossiers
assez précis
donc donc ma position à moi elle est
claire il ya beaucoup de mes confrères
qui m'ont reproché qui vous reprochent
et qui me dit que beaucoup plaint qu'ils
disent mais si on va avoir des infos il
faut aller voir des cafés avec eux
déjeuner dîner
ah ça oui ça peut aussi arriver mais non
ils vont pas jusqu'à me dire ce genre de
choses parce que moi je suis tellement
loin qu'il ya du bon et mais bon voilà
où ils me disent on n'a pas d'info si si
on n'a pas une certaine proximité avec
eux mais moi je pense que les infos
quand on les cherche on les trouvait que
les infos qu'il nous donne sont les
informations qu'ils veulent bien vous
connaissez le proverbe africain allez-y
cours tu te couches avec le diable le
lendemain matin quand tu te réveilles tu
sens encore le diable alors oui voilà
c'est ça mais vous mais même sans
coucher je pense qu'à un moment il faut
se poser la question de savoir pourquoi
un homme politique vous donne une
information ce qu'ils disent oui mais
c'est des contacts on nous donne des
informations mais une information ait
jamais donné gratuitement
parce que vous vous avez des questions à
nous poser
oui j'ai plein de questions à vous poser
parce que je pense que
vous avez des
des capteurs qu'on n'a pas
vous entendez vous sentez des choses
qu'on sent pas et que je pense qu'à un
moment cc c'est bien qu'on se parle
c'est à dire que
chacun est dans son rôle
faut pas jouer on est copains copains on
est potes c'est chacun est dans son rôle
mais que c'est très important parce que
nous on a beau être
sur le boulot à fond à voir des gens qui
nous parlent de plus en plus on a besoin
de gens qui sentent aussi des choses
dans la société et puis qui et puis qui
sortent des choses aussi qui voit qu'ils
sentent qu'ils sortent des infos qui
peuvent nous échapper parce qu'à un
moment on n'a pas de 12 cerveau
malheureusement ce serait bien ce serait
pratique mais on les a pas et qu' on a
besoin de voix là on a besoin de se
parler je suis pas là par hasard
le message est passé entre le coeur on a
l'habitude de demander nous inviter des
conseils pour les jeunes générations
si vous aviez laissé une bouteille à la
mer pour les jeunes générations ne
seriez quoi d'une façon immortel sur les
réseaux immortel personne ne l'est mais
l'a pour l'instant tout de suite
maintenant qu'est ce que je leur dirai
je leur dirai que la vie d'aujourd'hui
elle et elle est vachement difficile
parce que j'ai le sentiment que déjà
nous moi quand je jouais 20 ans on nous
faisait ou c'est la période du chômage
c'est la crise vous allez avoir du mal à
trouver du boulot
j'ai vraiment pas que le sentiment j'ai
la certitude que c'est beaucoup plus dur
aujourd'hui encore et donc on a tendance
dans ces moments là
à limiter ses ambitions et à se dire je
vais juste essayer d'avoir ça parce que
ça déjà avoir ça dans la société c'est
pas facile c'est compliqué juste faire
ma place et moi je leur dirai non payées
de l'ambition sortez de votre zone de
confort allez-y prenez des risques
il faut il ya où l'eau tiède ou l'eau
froide où l'eau chaude soyez pas tiède
quoi soyez froid ou chaud
distinguez vous ne vous font des pas
dans la masse je sais que la tentation
est grande parce que les risques sont
grands aujourd'hui dans la société mais
on ne voit que les gens qui se distingue
et
à pouvoir assumer vous prenez des
risques sortez de votre zone de confort
de toute façon vous le ferez pas
forcément après on peut toujours le
faire après mais
voilà ne vous laissez surtout pas aux
coupes et vaut elle restreint vos
ambitions vos envies vos rêves faites-le
sortait alesi et puis si vous ratez
c'est pas grave parce que on se souvient
pas forcément de ses échecs on se
souvient de ce qu'on a réussi puis vous
allez réussir après donc
voilà faut surtout pas se laisser
impressionner par cette société qui en
ce moment est en train de réduire les
champs elysées merci merci
[Musique]
je tremble habitants vont s'en laisse de
la chaire sur ma feuille tu manges tu
payes tu goûtes pas en tombant dans
l'eau mais en y restant le choix
satan dirige le théâtre tu écris ma
pièce la gentillesse est un mauvais
maître mais pas la sagesse des analystes
11 13 profite de ton silence parce que
le rap c'est comme si on veut lui c'est
un polonais sarkozy à balkany ne parle
pas d'économie sans parler des colonies
leur part à julien ma schizophrénie au
lieu devant ton cul tu ferais mieux de
temps donc qui te divise nourris si tu
me parlais cette malade est tiré par war
fonction puisque on partage le même
média
[Applaudissements]
l'un des choix qu'une banque fasse moi
une banquette bac 2 mois l'arrière d'un
bateau lui ses journaux font pas ce mois
et demi lui que jean
[Musique]